sorry an illegal immigrant named Jorge
who got caught selling crack can't be
deported because of an executive action
daca that's the top trend today
administration announced the end of daca
now here's something that's important
before we even move on with this okay
because the left is trying to go and I
understand they're going to try and
paint this as you know innocent kids who
are here who've been born and raised
here and oh my gosh how could you get
rid of as though this is their line in
the sand and so we can find some common
ground but this is well actually we
talked about this not too long ago on
this very show here's a clip from a
while back leftist always say you know
Republicans are the party of no we want
to find common ground okay let's get rid
of amnesty before you even get there or
before we even get to anchor babies I
understand that these are issues that
need to be discussed but right here
right now we are talking about deporting
illegal immigrants who are only found
exclusively because they got caught
committing crimes how is that if we
can't find common ground there there is
no common ground to be fun so before we
have the daca conversation the left
wants you to believe that they just kids
listen listen we just at this point
can't we all come together and care
about children yeah but here's the thing
you want us to all come together and
make it illegal to deport criminals who
are here committing crimes in prison so
let's be really clear when you want to
talk about open mindedness when you want
to talk about finding common ground the
left wants to find none they drew their
line with ilium the illegal immigration
keyword illegal long before daca and
that is they don't believe in borders
they don't believe in walls they don't
believe in deportation at all if you
look at their policies with that in mind
let's look through the daca timeline
1996 Bill Clinton administration they
passed what was called the illegal
immigration reform and immigration
Responsibility acts what does that mean
it made it nearly impossible for illegal
aliens to get legal status of course
that same applied for children that they
brought in with him now I understand I'm
not on I have empathy there these kids
didn't do anything wrong but their
parents did and this was again a bungled
government policy that wasn't well
thought out and so then we tried to
rectify it and sure enough when the
solution to a government problem is more
government intervention it snowballs it
gets worse
so 2001 the DREAM Act the children
became known as dreamers that's a term
you've heard dreamers it comes from this
after the DREAM Act it was meant to give
them a path to citizenship which was
kind of the concept I think introduced
somewhere in 2001
now 2012 this is where daca actually
comfortable for those who don't know
daca means deferred action for childhood
arrivals program so will who couldn't
childhood arrivals so you're just making
much people signs at the airport there's
Julian no so Congress stalled and Obama
was picked picked up his pen and he
decided to create daca now that doesn't
provide a path to citizenship daca we
need to be clear but it does protect
from deportation and permits these
people to work in the United States okay
are we clear on the timeline that's the
timeline is how daca came to be then
it's important how does the media the
media again who have said that it is
cruel and unconstitutional to deport
actively criminal illegal immigrants how
they painted dekha okay well Vox called
the ending of daca unprecedented so so
right there you know it's good
salon they wrote about Jeff Sessions
they called them for spreading
falsehoods about dreamers saying that
their criminal records were spotless
we'll talk about that later and that's
because the debt what's the definition
of crime we're a little Fe we're not
slates pushing the same narrative
innocent teenagers of course Zuckerberg
and other big CEOs are slamming this
decision okay
so what's wrong with daca why do we have
a problem with daca the way that
President Obama instituted daca is is
not how these things are supposed to
work go back to you know talk about
Schoolhouse Rock what three branches of
government anyone know anyone no
executive anyone no judicial legislative
okay daca it contrary that National
Review wrote about this contrarians the
just the basic principle that the
legislative ranch ought to be
legislative meaning passed laws and the
executive branch ought to enforce them
meaning they put the bill on your desk
you sign them that's your job with your
executive job so now daca rewrote
immigration law by unilaterally issuing
the issued work permits and deportation
relief to illegal immigrants
now here's what's important when you
look at this again that's why the salon
the Vox and the spotless record this is
what the left they do it very
effectively the human interest stories
in the foreground and then the facts
with the left on this case are nowhere
to be found or in the background and I
think I get that that's effective we'll
do that sometimes on this show are you
okay listen here's a personal connection
here's how people relate to it and then
you deliver the factual information here
it's it's a parlor trick it's human
interest in the foreground so that you
don't actually see the facts in the
background spotless criminal records
okay as Ronald Mortensen at the Center
for Immigration Studies he pointed out
most daca recipients not some most of
them have committed multiple felonies in
order to get jobs just among them Social
Security fraud forgery perjury and i9
forms falsification of green cars and
driver's licenses
identity theft now this matters why
because the left doesn't consider those
illegal actions when discussing
criminality so they'll say these people
have a spotless record what about the
Social Security fraud well we don't
count that pick everything we're
creating a false license they had it
have to get a job no this is why this is
what matters
legal acts versus illegal acts so if
someone just says well all the illegal
acts that are used to try and rectify
the situation of them being here
illegally you can't count that is crime
well yeah you can't yeah you can't I
don't know I think against Social
Security fraud perjury a forgery perjury
on i9 forms falsification of rigo's
these things are significant to me we
don't want to round up and get rid of
children because I'd listen I mean it's
just hard to not have your heart go out
to these people especially some kid I
didn't do anything wrong but hey can we
find common ground left can we find
common ground Barack Obama Joe Biden
Lena Dunham can we find common ground
all of Hollywood when it comes to you
know people who are who we catch them
incidentally committing crimes in there
yeah well you don't want to find common
brown that's what's important these same
people who are trying to make it seem as
though were somehow cruel still assume
still believe it to be cruel to deport
people who you catch committing a crime
by the way then they [ __ ] about
overcrowded prisons something else this
is this is the idea this is again this
is the parlor trick it's it's it's
creating this it's this victim culture
of losing these poor kids and it's a
false victim culture because most of
them are not poor little kids that's not
who were
talking about what we're dealing with
this um you forget the real victims
legal immigration has been at a level
about a million people per year since
the beginning of this century what about
those people what do you think happens
when you just sign with a stroke of a
pen you know what you're gonna be
untouchable you know what we're not
going to deport illegal aliens who are
also committing crimes and felonies here
because that would be cruel we're gonna
bog down the system we're gonna deplete
our resources because it's a nice thing
to do for people who really have no
business being here in the first place
what do you think that does for the
people there are people across the pond
it may not look as good on a postcard
there are people over there there are
people in Italy there are people in
Germany there are people anywhere across
the pond there are people who want to
come over here from Ireland from rural
parts of Ireland where they're there
down on their luck there's no economic
opportunity they're looking to the
American Dream and guess what they've
done they filled out the paperwork
they've signed the guestbook they've
gone through the process we're doing it
right now with an intern spend computer
who we want to get here it is very
difficult it is harrowing now imagine if
you did everything right you follow the
law because you want to come to this
country you want to take your
naturalization notes and you want to
become a contributing American only to
get to the end of that tunnel on someone
says sorry an illegal immigrant named
Jorge who got caught selling crack can't
be deported because of an executive
action you're screwing those people and
that's the problem just going on
feelings I get it you think of a kid
here whose parents brought him in they
use their children horrible parents use
their children to try and gain legal
status which they don't deserve I feel
bad for that kid but you can't you can't
legislate based on that feeling you have
to think of the other people who you
might feel bad for but don't get the
same amount of press time just like yeah
I feel bad for the guy with AIDS but I
feel a whole lot worse for the kid who
didn't go out and shoot heroin while
having gay butt sex in a truck stop and
he was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes
and has nothing to do with his actions
you can't go based solely on feeling you
have to go on what's right you have to
go on the constitutional parameters of
this country and what defines a citizen
and it does seem again they don't think
it's illegal to lie on these forms I
don't think it's illegal to falsify IDs
it seems like we need to revisit this we
do it every we've done this before but
it seems like we
need to break down again for you the
difference between a legal immigrant in
an illegal immigrant I'm legal and 90
legal I follow the law respected the
process you see I just came here
illegally to some immigration is nuanced
almost subliminal don't look at me I'm
just a criminal I worked a skilled trade
and pay legal taxes I just came here to
sell out of the cracks in I came here in
a work visa then took my naturalization
oath one time I killed a guy
it seems you're confused let's play a
game you ask if it's legal then I will
explain okay
pain stain tax legal selling cocaine
illegal buying a TV legal deeming a TV
[Music]
legal killing a guy in the government
illegal kidnapping for ransom illegal
I'm still going to do wait what clip
from the full show Daily Show at lotta
with credit calm / mug club or it's
available exclusively 69 dollars a year
that's less than six dollars a month
less than two expensive cups of coffee
or you can feed an African child but
just buy coffee or join the mug Club
Daily Show ladder with credit.com / mug
club see you there
don't feed children